une nouvelle fois front uni de tous les
syndicats aujourd'hui dans cette
manifestation à Paris que peut-on encore
cette intercer syndicale alors que la
réforme est adoptée le président a l'air
inflexible aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que
vous pourrez encore faire je crois qu'au
niveau continuez à mettre la pression
oui la réforme a été adoptée mais cette
réforme aujourd'hui est le peu encore
être retiré et je crois que c'est ça le
le combat nous avons aujourd'hui encore
dans les premiers chiffres qui nous
remontent plus d'un million de personnes
qui vont être dans la rue on est
légèrement supérieur apparemment au 31
janvier qui était déjà une très forte
mobilisation donc je crois que cette
pression au bout d'un moment elle va
peser elle va peser sur le président de
la République et son discours d'hier est
un discours de façade sur cette
confiance qu'il annonce en disant nous
allons pas retirer cette réforme
d'ailleurs on voit que le patronat
commence à réagir parce qu'il s'inquiète
de ces de tous ces mouvements on voit
que les marchés financiers sont beaucoup
plus inquiets de ces mouvements de grève
que le fait que la réforme se fasse ou
ne se fasse pas donc on voit que les
pressions arrivent de tout bord
aujourd'hui et en plus avec ce déni
démocratique ique par l'adoption par
49-3 et l'utilisation de 4 articles on
voit que ça met aussi beaucoup de gens
dans la colère et beaucoup de jeunes
dans la colère donc je crois que nous
allons continuer puisque nous allons
réussir à ce que cette réforme de passe
pas et puis on a aussi d'autres combats
en parallèle le combat avec le Conseil
constitutionnel parce que beaucoup de
articles sont ben oui beaucoup
d'articles sont discutables et nous
avons le référendum initiatique partagé
qui est aussi un combat premièrement
avant sur le
il manquerait dur qu'un employer le
président de la République hier à
l'endroit de Laurent Berger mais on a
l'impression que ça ça pourrait vous
inclure aussi tous les syndicats
qualifier qu'est-ce que vous vous en
avez heureux ce que vous avez perçu vous
avez pas proposé de compromis à
l'exécutif c'est ça j'ai envie de dire
quel culots et quel mensonge quel culot
de dire que les organisations syndicales
ont pas proposé de quoi en premier nous
avons à la CFTC un reconnu qu'il fallait
une réforme des retraites nous avons dit
que nous avions des propositions vous
avez accepté l'idée qu'il y a un déficit
dans le futur et nous allons proposer un
mix de solutions et dans le bureau de la
première ministre la même reconnu que
notre propositions étaient sérieuses
crédibles et constructive mais que
c'était pas leur choix donc autant vous
avez sur le financement un gouvernement
qui vous dit il y a une seule solution
un seul choix c'est le report de l'âge
légal
ils viennent pas de dire derrière qu'on
a pas voulu de compromis c'est eux qui
n'ont pas voulu discuter donc une autre
solution peut le report de l'âge légal
donc ça je dis calculons et quel
mensonge je sais venir nous dire que sur
les retraites il y a toujours que cette
de ce triptyque de solution c'est
insupportable tant que ça depuis quatre
mois on nous dit c'est soit
l'augmentation des cotisations soit la
baisse des pensions soit le recul de
l'âge non il y a des dizaines d'autres
propositions à faire et on l'a démontré
et le problème c'est que le gouvernement
nous regarde que du côté des dépenses et
des dépenses nous on a fait des tas de
propositions pour augmenter les recettes
aussi voilà donc c'est du mensonge c'est
du culot et honnêtement les mots qui ont
été dit tout le temps tout au long de
cette intervention y compris envers
certaines de mes collègues oui je pense
à Laurent Berger c'est c'est quand même
très dur et très méprisant moi je j'ai
entendu ça j'ai vu l'image de pour avoir
une image de foot banistique d'un tacle
par derrière les deux pieds décollés
quoi donc c'était enfin c'est pas comme
ça qu'on crée du conseil aussi c'est du
compromis et quand le Président vous dit
à deux reprises dans l'avenir il va
falloir faire un engagement collectif ah
oui très bien mais l'engagement
collectif on aimerait le voir en ce
moment on aurait aimé le on aurait aimé
le voir sur sur la réforme des retraites
donc nous tendre la main pour dire il
faut revenir dans trois mois dans trois
semaines comme si c'était rien passé je
crois que c'est complètement hors sol
c'est que j'avais dit on voit aussi un
durcissement quand même de la
mobilisation dans la rue avec de
nombreuses manifestations spontanées qui
sort un peu des cadres habituels de ce
que vous en tout cas vous vous faites
ici est-ce que ça vous inquiète un peu
aussi de voir que vous pourriez avoir
une certaine forme de radicalité c'est
pas trop votre truc à la CFTC qui
viendrait peut-être grever un peu le
message que vous voulez porter après
d'abord je vais d'abord tempérer et il y
a quand même énormément de mobilisation
qui sont d'ailleurs conduites par les
organisations syndicales immobilisation
de proximité qui se passe très bien ça
reste une minorité de rassemblement où
ça se passera je pense que c'est
important de le préciser et évidemment
que ça nous inquiète mais c'est pas pour
rien qu'on avait écrit au président pour
lui dire qu'on était au bord d'une crise
sociale ou d'une explosion sociale c'est
parce que ce mépris ce mensonge ça crée
de la colère la colère crée la violence
et la violence on la voit de tout bord
d'ailleurs j'ai eu des des violences de
la part des manifestants il y a eu des
choses aussi qui ont été violentes dans
certains endroits de la part de la
police mais tout ce contexte là créer ce
sent iment de violence donc et hier on
attendait justement un discours
d'apaisement du président et au
contraire il a soufflé sur les braises
donc on est inquiet mais on n'est pas
surpris parce qu'on avait prévu
j'ai encore deux questions la question
de ce soir sur l'intercy syndicale
Frédéric souiaud à l'instant nous disait
il y a pas un grain de sable entre nous
il y a pas un gravier qui nous sépare
l'Inter syndical va continuer ce soir
les terres syndicale elle va continuer
ce soir vous savez ça fait deux mois
pour nous prédit que la terre syndicale
va finir la semaine d'après donc ça fait
deux mois que les terres Sénégal tiens
bon on arrive à se mettre d'accord il y
a que aucun problème par rapport à ça
donc oui l'intersydicale se réunit ce
soir je suis persuadé qu'elle va trouver
encore un communiqué en commun des
moyens d'action en commun sans grande
sans grande difficulté et quand on voit
une mobilisation aussi forte aujourd'hui
on voit très bien que ce soir ne sera
pas la dernière intercanticale et un
dernier mot le seul Chabanier sur
peut-être votre espoir de voir peut-être
le Conseil constitutionnel s'assurer
tout ou partie de cette réforme est-ce
que ce serait ça maintenant votre salut
je crois que le salut y compris pour le
président ça serait de dire je retire ce
texte et on se remet autour de la table
ça tout le monde de sortir et je crois
la tête haute mais évidemment que si le
président ne va pas vers cette voix le
Conseil constitutionnel dans lequel on a
déjà eu l'expression de son président
qui avait dit que certains sujets
étaient très certains articles étaient
très discutables évidemment on a
beaucoup d'espoir par rapport au Conseil
constitutionnel et il y a aussi le
référendum d'initiative partagé obtenir
les 4,5 millions de signatures sur un
texte comme celui-là je crois que c'est
tout à fait faisable donc merci beaucoup
[Musique]